If you've been watching AI content
recently, then probably your feed is
filled with videos like this one, where
people are using Obsidian with Claude,
showing you this really nice animation
and saying that Claude is now basically
alive with his brain. Or videos like
these ones were saying it's Jarvis
basically talking to you and knowing
everything that you have about your
business.
And it's becoming a little bit
ridiculous online, where if you follow
these people, you can see like this guy
is starting with 30K MRR, then 100K MRR,
150, jumping to 550, and then 700, back
to 200. You see that back to 15K, uh
which is is like people are just faking
all these stuff, putting some nice demo
animation, and basically creating
content online, trying to hype you,
trying to sell you certain things.
So, in this video, we're going to
clarify what is actually useful in this
second brain concept, what is not so
useful and more into marketing and
hyping and stuff like that. Uh and my
goal after this video is that you will
get some clarity on what is it that you
can actually use in your business, so
you can move forward and be more
productive. So, let's jump in. So, my
problem started with Obsidian in
general. I have a founder friend who is
really busy, and all of a sudden, rather
than I see him selling and marketing his
services, I see him setting up Obsidian
because he told me that, "Bro, this is
the this is the thing that you need to
use with Claude, otherwise it doesn't
have a brain." Unfortunately, this is
the way that it was sold to people, and
a lot of people start installing
Obsidian and starting putting all this
data, so they can see this
visualization. And what YouTubers do,
and these guys on Instagram, they
literally just click on this button, and
they click on animate, so these nodes
start to move, and then it looks like,
"Oh my god, Claude is learning, right?"
And basically, if you zoom in on what is
these nodes actually doing, it just
tells you that this readme is connected
to this file, but it technically doesn't
provide you any insights that you can
use in your business. It's all just
bunch of nonsense. So, that's just for
the graph. The second thing with Cloud
Code, basically if you connect Cloud
Code to this, it does not have proper
search over your document. There is no
rag functionalities. And if you're
unfamiliar with rag, it's basically a
way to retrieve small chunks of text
that is most relevant to what you asked
for, helping the AI have better, more
accurate answers. And let's say you have
such a massive data that you need Cloud
to understand and search, you won't be
able to do this accurately because it's
going to search the way it usually
search, using code and searching with
these files. And the only advantage here
is like you have these files. Yeah,
sure, you can read them in normal text,
but the same thing you can do with just
normal Visual Studio Code. So, similar
to this. And this one is also for free.
Obsidian's also for free. But here at
least you can write actual code. So, if
you need to change the code here, if you
need to run it, this is the traditional
way of running code. So, there's
literally no difference of using Cloud
Code from here, from this terminal, and
you have the files here right next to
you, and you see what is changing and
what is not changing, than to use it
with Obsidian. If anything, with
Obsidian, there is no chat window as far
as I saw, that you can just use Cloud
Code here and edit here directly. You
need to have like somewhere else to do
this. I saw one advantage, if you have a
vault that you can connect this database
somewhere in the cloud so your team can
kind of see it. But then, it becomes
similar to Notion, similar to all these
other stuff. So, I don't understand the
specific hype about Obsidian in general.
And funny enough, I created a post about
this that also went viral on Reddit. And
basically, 300,000 people saw it. And my
point was is that I generally do not
understand the hype behind Cloud Code
and Obsidian, and people on YouTube
telling you that this is the agentic OS.
And if you don't use it like this, then
it's not agentic OS. I think this is
just a little bit misleading. And the
main point that is misleading is that
it's costing us time by learning a new
tool that is technically unnecessary
just because it's trending online. And
this is exactly my issue with these kind
of videos is that we are basically
wasting our time where we could have
been using AI that is really really
useful, but on things that actually move
the needle forward. Like how can we set
up this directory in a way that it is
connected, that it has some automations.
So, the most value that I got recently
from using Cloud Code and using Agentic
Workflows is when I automated my school
posting so on this community that I
have, my finance so it automatically
download all the invoices, the payouts,
and then pushes them to Google Drive
which is then getting sent to my
bookkeeping, stuff like that. So, all of
this is now I have in a folder where I
have like my agency OS and then I run
all these workflows. Also, N at Hand
workflows are connected here so Cloud
Code can see them, provision them, etc.
I have SaaS ideas, my strategy document,
even the website of my agency is here.
So, I have everything in one folder
without seeing the stupid nodes where it
just brings me nothing just because it
looks kind of nice. And my other issue
with running a voice AI assistant like
this, like Jarvis that tells you back
what you need to do, it just it's really
not necessary. It's just an extra cost
that you can basically do with a simple
automation that tells you what is
happening. For example, let's have a
look at this video.
>> Wake up, Adam Song. How's that doing?
>> Good evening, sir. Pulling up our ad
stats now. Over the last 7 days, our
campaigns generated 1.2 million combined
views and pulled in 8,400 user sign-ups.
For organic content, I'm still posting
45 short-form video
>> Yeah, sure. This video looks really
interesting when you see it and then you
can see the top comment for people who
have common sense is like, "Bro, how
much are you spending just to get the
stupid update?" Because voice AI is
pretty expensive and unless you're
replacing someone else like a virtual
assistant or an actual person who needs
to do something else like in doctors or
or or or actual clinics that they need
to be replaced to do maybe giving people
injections, which I actually saw, which
is a good use case to use voice AI in
that case, then it just doesn't make
sense to to put it here as a voice
assistant. You can just use cloud code
connected and give you a very short
update. But nevertheless, recently I've
been getting many of these videos and I
thought I'll make a very short update on
what I think makes sense to use and what
I think it doesn't make sense to use.
And if you want to use a second brain,
make sure to use as many automations as
you can that does not require tokens.
So, automations like this one, what I
did the downloading of the receipt,
which is literally just code that runs
without an actual agent that needs to
run it. This runs automatically, but
then you use the AI to create this
automation for you. That's how you
should think about it. The whole point
here is to reduce the cost and now even
with agents like today is the 7th and
I'm already using 70 4% of my agentic
coding. So, like we are burning all of
our limits within literally 7 days. So,
you need to be now more careful about
the prompting, about the use case, so
you can preserve these tokens and not
explode our AI spending. I hope this
video helped you get some clarity on how
to use a second brain in general and how
to use tools like Obsidian, etc. And if
you want me to do a deep dive about the
second brain and how I set up my second
brain for my AI automation and what I
think it makes sense to use it as
agentic and where I think it doesn't
make sense, let me know in the comments
and I'm happy to create a deep dive
video about that. Thank you so much for
watching and I see you in the next one.